welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Jason Chaffetz in for Sean
and breaking tonight Elon Musk is
officially lifting the veil at Twitter
and what we're learning about the tech
Giants role in the 2020 election it's
downright horrific according to internal
Twitter documents from 2020 shared with
journalist Matt taibi Twitter employs
regularly fielded content moderation
questions primarily from Democrats and
the Biden campaign and then acted
quickly to remove content they didn't
like much of this objectionable content
included graphic images and videos of
Hunter Biden and his laptop from hell
in fact Twitter employees were so
desperate to censor the New York post's
very real story about hunter's laptop
that they even blocked users from
sharing the story through emergency
technology typically used to block the
dissemination of child pornography now
make no mistake the level of left-wing
bias and Corruption at Twitter was
extreme this comes on the heels of new
testimony from a federal agent who
claims that the FBI held weekly meetings
with major Tech platforms ahead of the
2020 election to quote discuss
disinformation on social media and ask
about efforts to censor that information
in other words your federal government
was colluding with big Tech to shape the
outcome of a presidential election but
for some reason the Biden Administration
is doing little to counter the
disinformation on Tick Tock where the
Communist Party of China is actively
interfering in our elections With viral
social media accounts that promote
Democrats and attack Republicans hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else